翻訳: Shinnosuke Kinoshita
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
僕は 浜松で生まれて育ち
現在 競技ヨーヨーのプレイヤーとして
浜松を中心に活動しています
今日は 僕がアジア大会で準優勝するまでの
経緯をお話ししたいと思います
まず 僕のヨーヨーとの出会いは
小学５年生の春でした
公園で遊んでいた時に たまたま
友達がヨーヨーを持ってきたんです
初めて見たヨーヨーは こんな感じ
え？ どうなってんの？
当時の僕にとって ヨーヨーを始める
きっかけとしては十分でした
すぐに その場にいた全員で
ヨーヨーを始めました
最初はみんな 技を練習したり
誰が一番長く回るかを競ったりして
ヨーヨーを楽しんでいたんですが
１ヶ月ぐらいすると
みんなヨーヨーに飽きて
サッカーを始めてしまい
当時 運動が苦手だった僕だけが
ヨーヨーを続けていました
僕が初めて大会に出たのは
ヨーヨーを始めて２年目
浜松で 大きなヨーヨーの大会が
開催された時でした
大会の一週間前から 毎日練習をして挑んだ
人生で初めての大会
結果は57人中51位
とてもショックを受けました
でもその時
自分の何がダメだったんだろうって
考えることすらしませんでした
なぜなら 自分のヨーヨーに
可能性を感じていなかったからです
僕の技には オリジナリティが
備わっていませんでした
その後も大会では
順位は少しずつ上がっていったのですが
やる技は 初めて大会に出たころと
全く変わっていない
何年も同じ技ばっかりやっていて
つまんない
そう感じていました
そんな時に僕は
５つあるヨーヨーの部門の中から
オフストリングという部門に
挑戦することにしました
オフストリングは 紐とヨーヨーが
離れている部門です
わけがわからないですよね？
でも その状態から繰り出される技は
ダイナミックで どの部門よりもリスキー
僕はそんなとこに惹かれました
でも実際にやってみると
ミスすると ヨーヨーは転がっていくし
何度も落とすと壊れてしまう
何度も あきらめそうになりました
そんな時に 僕を支えてくれたのは
同じオフストリングを
メインでやっている先輩の存在でした
彼を超えたい
その一心で 僕は必死に練習を続けました
いまでは その人と一緒に出る大会では
ほとんど僕が勝ってるんですけどね
（笑）
ヨーヨーを オフストリングを
始めてしばらくすると
自分の中に これだけは絶対に
欠かせないものができました
それは 難易度とオリジナリティです
誰もやらないような難しい技を
ステージで確実に決めることができたら
絶対にかっこいい
僕はそう思って
演技に入れる技は
人がやっていた技や 一般的な技を
なるべく省くようにしました
最初のころは
ただやりたい技を演技に入れてたため
ミスが多く 大会で決めることができなくて
見せたい技も見せれない
そんな状態が続いていました
これはいかん！と思って 僕は考えました
考えた結果
すごく単純ですが 練習量を増やしました
できない技は できるまでやる
できなかったら演技から抜く
それと 放課後３時間やっていた練習を
大会の３週間前
１ヶ月前
１ヶ月半前 と増やしていった結果
去年までは全国大会で
予選落ちしていた僕が
今年は決勝で３位入賞
そして アジア大会では準優勝という結果を
手にすることができました
でもまだ 最大の結果を
手にしたわけではありません
これまで がむしゃらにやってきたことを
さらに がむしゃらにやったら
ここまでこれたんだから
次は世界一という夢をかなえるために
僕はさらにがむしゃらに もっとがむしゃらに
頑張っていこうと思います
そして このヨーヨーと出会い
ヨーヨーによっていろいろ変わった７年間
この７年間を絶対に無駄にしたくない
という思いから
僕は今 ヨーヨーで
パフォーマーをやろうと考えています
プロのパフォーマーへの第一歩だと思い
いま僕はここの この
TEDxHamamatsuの舞台に
立たせていただいています
そして僕はパフォーマーですから
今からパフォーマンスをするわけですが
今日使うヨーヨーを紹介したいと思います
今日使うのは
この一般的なヨーヨー
たぶん皆さんから見たら
一般的じゃない形をしてるんですけど
これが１番 今は一般的なヨーヨーなんです
これと 僕が今
現在大会で出場しているオフストリング
この２種類のヨーヨーを
使った演技になります
２種類のヨーヨーの
動きの違いに注目しながら
ご覧ください
（拍手）
（音楽）